foreign
[Applause]
Valley already reverberates to wales's
World Cup soundtrack
of defiance and survival of the national
culture and identity
the energy and passion that's taken
Wales to Qatar they love football do you
love football
Rob page is the first manager in 64
years to lead Wales on football's
biggest stage you know the buzz around
the place now is incredible and as a
nation we're all we're all looking
forward to it what's it going to mean to
the nation actually finally being back
at a World Cup for the first time since
58. well it's like everybody said you
know little or Wales qualified for a
World Cup you know we're not a country
of of you know millions and millions of
people so to do what we've done is an
incredible achievement
Gareth Bale can always be relied on for
a team not overflowing with superstars
the first name a 26-man squad now
decided that flies next week
so much Focus will be on Qatar in the
coming weeks but this is where the
excitement is in Wales where Rob page
has come back to his hometown of Tyler's
town to experience the further growing
in the local community and a return
finally for Wales to the World Cup
but they are also confronting the darker
side of this World Cup the human rights
abuses and anti-lgbt laws that will see
bailware a one love multi-colored
armband in Qatar we win in the armband
um you know we make a stance on that
we're not going to change our beliefs in
what we are and what we do and what we
stand for so um we hope that after the
tournament we've used this as a platform
for positive change
but the main focus for Paige is figuring
how to beat the United States Iran and
of course England and Qatar to start
with at a World Cup which isn't just
about competing on the pitch but
harnessing a platform for the red wall
of fans to show pride in the nation and
the spirit of comrie Rob Harris Sky News
the Ronda Valley
[Applause]